foreign
[Music]
I came all the way from Brazil to talk
to you about how to make awesome
automations with GitHub actions
so anyone here has to run scripts like
every day every week every month
if you do that get up actions probably
will be useful to you
so I'm here to talk about what is GitHub
actions and how can we run our scripts
with it
so
um GitHub actions has been heavily
used by our package package developers
and for running checks on packages
building the package website and
documentation and if you are a package
developer you can easily do that using
package use this which is my favorite
package and you can also see a lot of
other examples in this awesome alib
actions Repository
so uh how important is GitHub actions to
our studio
and pause it so I look up in the GitHub
action API GitHub API to to get the
action run and we can see that in two
years the runs completed runs for these
these organizations which stores our
favorite packages uh increase it more
than four times so GitHub actions is
really important for our studio and
pause it to run checks on our packages
and build the documentation and stuff
but I told you about what package
developers can do but most people that I
know are not package Developers
so
I'm here to talk about you guys uh how
uh you can use that as well I've been
using in two years and in the beginning
was a bit hard for me so I'm trying to
facilitate this process right so we can
run arbitrary R scripts like scraped
data from the internet I do that a lot
but the government data run reports with
are marked down in quarto we can send
emails and save results all doing GitHub
actions
with art so this is a simple example of
a workflow file but I don't expect you
to uh understand this right now but the
point is this first part
um we have the events and we we this
part tells when the the workflow should
run in this case we have a button to
press so when we press a button we we
start the workflow and also we have a
schedule so I'm telling the computer
that it has to be run every day
the second part is the name of the
workflow and the third part is what the
workflow should do so the this part of
the jobs part imagine that is a virtual
machine that belongs to GitHub there's
nothing installed and you have to tell
what it should what should be installed
in order to run our script and what
should be done so I'm telling that I
want to run a Ubuntu machine you can
also use like Windows machine and apple
machines
Mac OS machines and I'm installing arm
but this is super easy because of the
r-lib action repository there is a lot
of setup there that we just use it and
then I'm saying that I run to I want to
run my awesome R script in the end and
remember that part you'll have to
install all the packages there otherwise
it won't work it will break so this is a
really quick uh presentation and I
prepared more examples in my blog and I
can I I hope I will continue to to do
that so you can see more examples there
I would like to think especially our
studio for the Diversity Scholarship
otherwise I couldn't be here our ladies
chrisway the creators and contributors
of early elections and articulation and
you can find me on Twitter and my blog
is bearmills.com thank you
foreign
[Music]